how does a filmmaker show an idea i
believe in ancestry you know and uh
and legacy and and now things don't go
away i want to show you a technique
director derek see in france uses to
communicate abstract concepts visually
in the place beyond the pines an
underrated film from 2013 that i'm about
to completely spoil the place beyond the
pines is about the passing of the torch
our legacy affects our children and
those around us our actions have
consequences and those consequences echo
out from us affecting those around us
sometimes for generations and while this
is something we understand almost
instinctual II about real-life it can be
hard to convey that on screen one way
you could do this is to edit the story
nonlinearly highlighting the connection
between actions and their consequences
but see and France decided to show Pines
linearly in three distinctive acts so
how do you show the relationship between
two events separated by minutes or hours
of film how do you connect Luke Clinton
who's only alive in the first 50 minutes
of the movie and his son who's only on
screen in the last 50
like this
and the director's commentary track for
the film see in France talks about how
many of the scenes have echoes later in
the film visual motifs and reoccurring
locations that show how you can feel
connected to someone's legacy even after
they've been dead for 15 years with
shots like these we can connect a father
and sons shared love of riding their
free spirits we can connect their crimes
and show how they develop similar
friendships these visual connections
help the audience understand
relationships between figures that are
hardly ever on screen together he's
yours
one holdin a scene towards the end of
the film where Jason visits the trailer
his dad lived in 15 years earlier
visually echoes the scene where Luke
sees the trailer for the first time
these two scenes are an hour apart in
the film but when I cut them together
you can see how clearly they interact
with each other the feeling of
connection that the characters are
feeling in that moment is palpable to
the viewer our memory is triggered and
we recognize the composition of the
scene from before and it puts us
emotionally in the shoes of the
character for a month come on I'll tell
you yeah yeah yeah yeah you're calling
back but seeing France doesn't just use
these echoes to connect father and son
he uses it to compare and contrast look
at this scene where Jason eats ice cream
for the first time with his biological
father alongside a later scene where he
eats ice cream at the same place with
the man that raised him the second scene
could have happened anywhere but by
placing it here the specter of Jason's
biological father looms over the entire
moment in the same way he looms over
Jason's life and we immediately know
that this statement is not you flawed
doesn't find its mark
another one would you leave me the
similarities between the scenes where
Luke and Avery try to give money to
Romina help drive home how the conflict
that entered her life with Luke will
continue well past his death hey hey
don't worry it's okay I don't know what
that is you don't have to ever even see
me again just take the money
we can see just through the visual
subtext how this relationship has had an
impact on this one
the scene where Bradley Cooper's
character picks up Luke's son from the
crib echoes an earlier scene where Luke
comforted and held his own son
we can see how this child has had an
impact on these two men in similar ways
and setting these two scenes at a pool
reinforces how we're a ver II had a
strong connection with his dad he lacks
one with his son film is a powerful
medium for storytelling because it gives
you so many options simultaneously for
how to communicate ideas cm France uses
these echoes to almost get inside your
head at times as the viewer were
affected but we might not even
understand why I think the themes in
Pines are most strongly communicated
visually through Sean Bobbitt's
beautiful cinematography and the staging
and locations of each scene I've only
covered some of the echoes that are in
the place beyond the pines but I'll
leave you with a side-by-side comparison
of the first and last shots of the film
the entire thrust of the story
can be summed up by the comparison of
these two shots the generational
evolution is clear jason is similar to
his father and it's easy to imagine him
as a young Luke in this shot but where
Luke rides into a cage
Jason rides off into freedom to the
place beyond the pines
I'm Thomas flight thank you so much for
watching this has been another video for
my series off the screen if you want to
see more videos like this hit the
subscribe button and maybe consider
sharing this video with someone who you
think might enjoy it as always I love to
hear from you let me know in the
comments what are some unusual ways
you've seen directors communicate
subtext that's all for this video I'll
see you all next time